comme vous le constatez on a déjà
commencé à mettre en place notre
terrasse on à la distanciation
absolument partout on a plus d'un mètre
vingt ou 1 mètre 50 entre chaque table
voilà comment s'organise la terrasse de
la ferme de voisins comme beaucoup de
restaurateurs romain gicquel doit
jongler entre les différentes mesures
sanitaires mais il reste confiant
partout 19 mai nous ouvrons la terrasse
si le temps le permet nous allons
continuer le click and collect et à
partir du 9 juin
nous ouvrons l'intérieur du restaurant
donc midi et soir sont moins cette
période de fermeture a été mise à profit
par la ferme de voisins qui a pu étoffer
sa carte et faire quelques aménagements
nous a quand même permis il faut rester
positif de faire des travaux et des
améliorations dans l'établissement pour
recevoir les gens à nouveau de la
meilleure des façons
du côté du bar restaurant o dan pâtit la
préparation est en cours
même si certaines d'appréhension
persiste on est déjà prêt pas comme vous
dites comme on est restés ouverts tous
les
les fournisseurs tous les clients ceux
restés un petit peu au contact donc pour
ça c'était peut-être un peu plus facile
que pour des restos conduit vraiment
fermer leur frigo on a quelques encore
de négociation à faire au niveau de la
restauration au niveau des jauges de 50%
malgré ces craintes le restaurateur vous
rassure des stocks sont déjà fait au
niveau de la bière vous soyez tranquille
elle est prête pour mercredi prochain
s'il fait beau les clients devraient
donc être nombreux dès mercredi sur les
terrasses pour entamer cette réouverture
progressive jusqu'au 30 juin
avec la levée totale des restrictions
sanitaires